[Music]
hi my name is christy foster i'm 18
years old and i'm a graduating senior
in the middle of a pandemic my school is
doing everything online
online classes online tutoring sessions
i haven't even stepped foot on campus
since
march since we left hey guys my name is
jimmy hernandez i am 17 years old
i am a senior this year and i live in
arkansas
i'm going to be going to school in
person and it's honestly going to be
very interesting to see how this year
goes
i'm going to look at this school year in
a positive way i'm going to try to make
it
the best year ever because like this is
our senior year guys this is the chapter
where it all
ends next thing you know we're writing
our own new book
am i scared to be honest i am but i got
this
[Music]
i don't want to go to school
good morning good morning
so i just woke up like 20 minutes ago
a normal school day for me will usually
start with me
going to practice at 5 00 a.m and then i
will usually
come straight home take a shower and
then i will
go to school looking like trash nobody
really cares what you look like over a
camera to be completely honest
this is my breakfast i heard like a lot
of sodium was like just
really good in the morning so i really
care about nutrition as you can tell
let me tell you guys my morning routine
i just uh wake up
brush my teeth do my hair get my coffee
and i'm out of here
it's really hard to get my coffee to
start my day off sticking to the
flavoring
and then i have to play some mickey
mouse cartoons on my brother's tv
say hi hi so my grandma doesn't go
berserk as well
with him um oh my god it's 7 34 i'm
gonna be late hold up
just need to get my mask in my car
the car that i will be taking to school
psych this is actually my ride she's a
beauty works like
queen um oh shoot dog so it's uh
sprinkling raining whatever so yeah i'm
gonna go back
myself to school in the rain i'll see
you guys in school
so it is that time to go to school so
let's go to school
[Music]
done i save a lot of gas money this way
i'm also in california which is
currently on fire especially my area
because i'm in the bay area
fire literally on fire mad max ish
a lot of my practices have been getting
cancelled due to the really bad air
quality
i know the bay area is just affected
really bad right now i'm tired
and that is my beautiful school right
there a beautiful high school
yeah there's so many stairs in the
school
what else are you going to um i'm going
to algebra what about you jimmy
ap spanish oh yes scholar
basically my life is on canvas and zoom
right now
without those two things we probably
wouldn't even have school
here are some of my classes anatomy ap
gov
ap reach english stats and
leadership everything is on the computer
but some teachers will still hand out
paperwork because
they know that that's going to help us
writing instead of like typing it out
honestly i love that you know why i'm
always losing my stuff
now that i haven't like in one device
and i don't have to worry about losing
papers it's like a whole way lifted off
my shoulders i'm like dude
thank you bless to be honest i don't
really like this
online situation i'm taking some pretty
hard classes this year and
learning over screen is just not the
same as learning in person especially
because
our class periods have been cut down to
an hour each
so that's a complete chunk of school
that we're missing
wear your mask at all times practice
social distancing
so this is what i have to do every day
now for the rest of our
school year honestly they have these all
over the hallways
and they honestly don't work
wait hand sanitizer every day we have to
do a health screening
before we go to fire because supposedly
we're only supposed to sing
in an area for 30 minutes and then after
that we have to leave that area
because germs or gym dream germs or
whatever um
yeah it's pretty whack
should i be focusing in gov right now
instead of playing this typing game
absolutely but do i care
no that's what online school will do to
a person
it's time for lunch finally i'm so
hungry before i'm starving
beautiful let's see what they're serving
today
we got some carrots organic juice
today i got a cheeseburger scrumptious
i'm done with my first two classes and
this is my lunch
chocolate milk turkey spinach wrap
popcorn after that i will literally do
nothing
i might have like a weightlifting
session
but usually what i'll do and this might
sound really stupid
i can't really see my friends i i it's
it's not worth risking it for the virus
but i will literally go to target
walk around not buy anything i just need
to see people
and it sounds stupid i know but it
cures my social craving going to the
dance room um
like always the instrument is my safe
haven
oh and it's locked am i late
wait am i late so i guess i made it to
class late i'm so sorry guys that's kind
of embarrassing on me
so we're all ready to perform
competition time yeah
we're doing a group project we're having
a competition with our own classmates
seeing who's the best of the best then
we're going to win
[Music]
oh time to go
i love that class she's honestly the
teacher she's honestly
the reason why i still go to school so i
just got done with my three classes for
the day
and um that was probably the most boring
time of my life
which is my reality now um
i swear it is so hard to stay motivated
i know that this is the best option
because
going to school right now is just not a
smart thing
and then in my areas actually hit really
hard my school too
there's a few people that have been
diagnosed with
kovid and i don't want to get it so i
guess this is
good i guess this is about it so i
stayed after
school for a little bit just to work on
a project for film
and uh now i'm leaving and it's good
because like all the cars are gone and i
can back home
safely high school it's gonna be okay
i can tell yeah it's crazy that we all
have to wear masks and do
things differently i know it's going to
be okay
it's my senior year and then they make
it the best senior year
all right guys it's sad to say goodbye
but you know
all good things happen sometime hope you
guys enjoyed this
video peace out girl scouts and
i'm out
[Music]
you